oh yeah
Ukraine's counter-offensive continues to
gain ground but has yet to lead to a
decisive breakthrough
as the attrition continues on the
battlefield
and drones attack targets inside Russia
the economists senior editors in London
and Kiev discuss how ukrainians are
preparing for the war to last for years
and what that means for the future of
the conflict
the real question is not in is this
Ukrainian offensive going to smash the
Russian lines I think that's unlikely
the real question we face is how does it
set both sides up for the next phase of
this war particularly the spring
fighting to come next year because this
is turning into a longer War of
Attrition ukrainians have recognized
that this is going to be a long War this
has become a new normal I think
ukrainians actually don't like now
talking about the timelines there's
almost a irritation with people saying
you know when is it going to end it will
end when Ukrainian Victory comes it's an
existential War the economy that people
and particularly the mindset has to to
adjust to that increasingly I worry
about the difficulty of selling this you
know the message was this
counter-offensive is coming it's going
to be important we're going to measure
um Ukraine's progress but there isn't a
story out there about how this war is
going to be won and it's a very
difficult message to sell
um you know we we there's not gonna be
much progress but we're still supporting
you let's lower expectations here but
this is still a worthy fight I think
it's important that leaders of Ukraine's
allies start to reframe this fight and
say what it's about because the
narrative has got left behind
and there is of course a second front in
this war which has become much more
visible in the past few weeks which is
uh the capability of Ukraine to lob
drones inside Russian territory the
range of Ukrainian drones is going up uh
the the capacity the payload they can
carry is going up we're now seeing um
not just strikes on politically
sensitive Targets in Moscow but also and
I think this is just as important
um quite low cost strikes against things
like strategic bombers you know so we
saw a tuple F 22 strategic bomber taken
out by a low-cost Ukrainian drone this
is bringing a war back to Russia Putin's
war from the very beginning rested on
the idea that this is a special military
operation uh not a war and nothing is
going to change for you the picture has
been uh cracking and now shattering for
for some time Moscow airports have been
closed uh almost every other day flights
diverted for an ordinary Russian For
Whom the war was on television is is now
really starting to question what is
going on here how long is this going to
go on for for Russia so I think what's
happening on the home front uh on the
Deep strikes inside Russia is now as
important to watch as what's happening
on the front lines a big concern all the
way through the war has been about
Russia's escalation and one reason why
the Americans have not given uh
particularly the Americans but the
Germans as well have not given
um ukrainians higher caliber weapons
earlier has been the fear that this
might provoke Russian escalation it's
very interesting to see that Ukraine is
now routinely striking inside Russia
without provoking a reaction at all and
I wonder how that will affect
um the outside world's willingness to
give Ukraine the weapons it needs the
pressure on Russia will be kept up by
these kind of means and I think that
that is going to be an important part of
the battle of attrition that will
continue through the winter and will
shape the balance of power on the Tucson
live to the beginning of 2024.
one of the reasons why I think it's
futile to think about peace right now is
is that on neither side feels that that
they've reached a sense of conclusion
that there's no point in fighting on
both sides think that they can prove
something if they just last longer on
the battlefield I think the most
important question for me is the balance
of attrition and the position that
Ukraine is in to be able to inflict
continued attrition so first of all not
just how far have they got but how
weakened are they have they got
something left in the tank can they
reconstitute over the winter period or
are they completely spent in ways that
make them exceptionally vulnerable my
sense of how this war ends is when the
people around Putin have a feeling that
that it's futile there is no real theory
of Victory available that that money and
lives are just being wasted nutrition is
not just about the rate of artillery
supplies of the shells of the military
progress attrition is about economic
strength about cohesion of societies
because uh for Ukraine and I've been
only reminded about this all too
powerfully uh while being here this is
an existential war and that requires
mobilization not just people at the
front it requires mobilization of
economic resources of new ways of uh of
doing things of reforming and learning
how to to survive and live
and retain your values uh in this war so
it's about economy it's about social
cohesion it's about political
institutions about holding things
together on the Ukrainian side and the
same is true for Russia it's the
societal and economic and political
factors that I think I will be watching
most carefully in this world attrition
thanks for watching if you found the
conversation about the conflict in
Ukraine interesting and want to see more
of the paper's coverage why not take out
a subscription to The Economist for the
best deals click on the link